Hello nice to meet you Antonio and Brian
I'm Sheridan I'm so glad to be able to
meet you both today
um so just to get started
um all my questions are gonna be for
both of y'all so just chime in
um what made y'all decide to go on the
ultimatum like was it what made you do
it yeah yeah
um I personally I mean Roxanne doesn't
feel the same way probably but I knew
from the moment that I met her that she
was a person I want to spend the rest of
my life with so that was always in the
back of my mind and then um honestly it
was after watching the first season of
the ultimatum I was like
there's no way I'm gonna get her in a
position where she has to figure this
out if I don't do something like this so
I mean the season ended we watched the
watch we watched the last episode I
looked at her I was like we should do
that at the same time she goes I would
never do something like that so so it
was pretty funny it was I had to work on
her for a little while but um uh
you know once we got started in the in
the process you know she was like oh
this is actually happening okay all
right let's do it so we did it wow for
me I think well Lisa it was like
um she didn't kind of really understand
why you know I wasn't trying to move
forward towards marriage right like in
that moment right because she felt like
you know which in her own right like
everything was already perfect for us
like we've been doing all the things
that a married couple would actually be
doing or moving towards that steps but
for me I just felt like it wasn't the
time right like I felt like it was still
a lot more stuff that we needed to kind
of work on and work towards
um but I felt like the experience would
definitely like bring that out like it
would bring definitely the truth out as
to like whether or not marriage like
we're ready for marriage now or
you know maybe we need to hold off for a
little bit longer or maybe we don't need
to be together but I mean in the back of
my mind I knew like I wanted to be with
her no matter what um and I was actually
like rolling the dice you know what I'm
saying by by deciding to come on the
show because it you know it more and
more it made her realize like maybe this
isn't the person I should be with
because he's not ready to marry me right
now so
um but I'm a person who takes risks and
I think it was definitely a risk worth
taking
absolutely absolutely so this obviously
is more so towards the Antonio uh was
the experience what you hoped it would
be I mean yeah it was like high stakes
therapy you know like I I was forced to
address all the pla all the ways that I
fall short as a human being as a partner
universally with anybody
um and
and I really got to work on those things
and I am so
satisfied and proud of of how I came out
on the other end
um as far as being able to work on the
things that I've never really been good
at and then see real progress and at
least like a um like a road map to how
to continue to be good at those things
and and how to continue to improve and
um and really it was like therapy I mean
it's not often that you are forced to
have a conversation about how you fall
short as an individual
um and and then also have to come up
with a road forward to to be better
about it so
um it was hugely beneficial for me uh in
growth
all right awesome awesome now Brian I
know you had a
shorter time
as well same question
in terms of what I got out of it yes
right
um in terms of like the uh the series of
events maybe not what I expected right
but
um at the end of the day I feel like I
still got the outcome that I was looking
for
um and you know and for me it wasn't
like a a manner of like oh I'm trying to
one-up Lisa right like and show her that
like we don't need to be married like
you know but I want the best decision
for the both of us at the end of the day
absolutely and it seems like hopefully
you all made that best decision for the
both of you yeah yeah so
so what is
uh that you both got from the show
run run towards your problems
run right at them they're not going
anywhere so you better face them and you
better solve them
sooner the better
yeah and for me I would say it's like
you get out of it what you put in
um you know we could have came on and
just like went completely left or
against the experiment and not really
like be true to it or ourselves and I
don't think we would have got the
outcome you know we got now so from the
beginning you're both being immediately
told all right this is the setup this is
what you need to do you need to start
getting to know these people after now
that your exes again
um were you surprised by how easy it was
to build connections with other people I
mean I want to say I was surprised that
the connection it was easy to build
connections because I think that like
you know everybody was there for similar
reasons in a way so like there was going
to be some connections there but for it
for us to like just literally be with
our partners and then start making
connections I think that kind of was a
hard pill to swallow for a lot of people
yeah I I think you know everyone's
essentially everyone's there for the
same reason I I think there's a level of
just like a cohesion that comes from
that so like you're you kind of get to
high step over that awkward initial
getting to know somebody phase and and
nobody's people kind of let their guards
down a little bit and and you really do
start to ask each other real questions
like right off the rip you know these
are not normal First Dates like it's not
like oh hi where are you from you know
what's your favorite hobbies it's like
how do you feel about kids you know how
do you feel about marriage you know how
do you feel about you know being the man
in the relationship and and the should
the women pay you know just asking like
real questions like that
um I think it's unavoidable that you
form connections quickly with with the
people that are a part of the experience
nice so what is one thing that you want
the viewers to know when they're
watching that's my last question for you
it's real
it's real it's real if I could if I
could conjure up tears on command I'd I
would not be on reality television I'd
be a really good actor
I mean yeah I cried so much and it was
all so real so I mean we're really going
through it we're really going through it
it's not easy it's you know it's not
easy it's not enjoyable it's hard it's
really hard right there's definitely no
acting and it's like if you're going
through
if you're going even through like an
inch of what we went through and we
definitely feel for you not in a bad way
but like that you are hopefully working
towards like being a better person right
and um you know building a better
relationship if that's the kind of the
path that you're on I think that's
probably like something I will like
would love for people to know when
watching is that like yeah
we're really in the
in there nice well that I'm hoping they
take that to heart thank you both so
much for your time today I really
appreciate it thank you have a good one